now at some point growing up most of us
have been captivated by one of these a
slinky but recently I found out one of
the most mesmerizing things about how it
moves is something I'd never seen before
how it falls so what's so surprising
about a falling slinky that's what I
expected well to help explain is
physicist rod cross the idea is that I
hold the top end of the sneaking like
this and then let the bottom and dangle
so this link is dangling freely and then
I'm going to drop this link but I want
you to predict what's going to happen
will the top end fall first will a
bottom and fold first or both ends fall
together or will the two and approach
each other in the middle that is a tough
question when I let go what is the
bottom deer shoot off it's gonna fall
it's great it's actually gonna fall
bottom goes up top goes down it might
come up yeah
oh you're gonna see the top come down to
the middle and the bottom come up to the
talk will accelerate faster than the
bottom
I reckon that bottom will stay there we
should come down to there and another
all right why don't we give it a shot
here I want you to watch the whole
slinky as it falls to see what it's
doing is kind of down Hey three two one
the problem is it's a bit hard to tell
with the naked eye just what's happening
no ID thing okay Campbell bottom come up
I couldn't be sure too fast
yeah to really appreciate the physics
involved you need to see it in slow
motion oh that's great that's
unbelievable
it just I just say that
just stays it like in midair it's
suspended doesn't move at all you
explain that you've got to look at
what's happening at the bottom and
gravity is pulling the bottom and down
tensions pulling the bottom and up the
two forces are equal and opposite so the
bottom end remains at rest then I let go
at the top end the tension in the spring
changing but it propagates down the
spring coil by coil until it reaches the
bottom end and that takes about a
quarter of a second and then the bottom
end falls so the tension doesn't
actually change at the bottom end until
the rest of the slinky has collapsed
correct the same principle applies to
sporting equipment like tennis racquets
or golf gloves when contact is made with
the ball a wave travels up the shaft so
the golfers hands don't feel the hit
until after the ball is already on its
way to the hole now as a final extension
on this experiment we've tied a tennis
ball to the base of the slinky we're
gonna drop it and see what happens this
time incredibly the same thing happens
that's because the slinky has simply
stretched further and reached a new
equilibrium where the gravitational
force down equals the tension force up
it didn't make a difference
it is Katerine charity but that's what
makes physics so interesting that's why
I keep doing experiments like this